the way i was explaining it earlier is
that you have
for you know we had these uh uh i think
there were two 49 state
um landslides it was nixon and i think
reagan
and the democrats according to the wall
street journal have called every single
election they've lost other than those
two illegitimate going back to i think
1968 or something this is a wall street
journal article about this wow
so why is it that we had these two
landslides for republicans
what i think happens is over time
political activity among regular
working-class people starts going down
why
because life's all right you know like
we get by
first of all we're spending most of our
time working we're not out there
protesting and screaming about
everything non-stop
you go to work you come home you take
care of your family you mind your own
business and life's
overall pretty good you might vote
passively but because they get passive
and they become the silent majority the
crazies start taking control
now the loudest voices are fringe
lunatics like we're seeing today
forcing regular people to get up and get
angry it's almost like
you're sitting at home eating dinner and
you hear a weird really annoying sound
outside
and you're like it'll eventually stop
let's just keep eating dinner
yeah i'm tired i just got off work but
it doesn't stop in fact
it's getting louder and louder and then
finally you go enough
and you throw down your your tablecloth
and you get up you go outside and you
yell at the kids
shut up and the kids showed up i like
your that tweet you showed me
which one with the guillotine oh yeah do
i have that one that sums up it sums
this up
so perfectly oh you do yeah you do check
this out
i don't really care about politics okay
well your head's about to be chopped off
from the politics you don't care about
so what's funny is the guy who who made
this is actually a leftist
and he makes a bunch of really dumb
comics
okay he made one uh this is how i found
this actually he made one
where it was a guy standing behind
hitler
saying i don't agree with what you say
but i'll defend the death you're right
to say interest
and he was like modern centrists be like
or whatever okay
and so i saw that i'm like dude you can
literally buy hitler's book on amazon
in like you know a bunch of different
versions of it there's like
stylized art it's ridiculous but yes
there's a reason why you can hear the
words of this lunatic
so you can understand why he was a
lunatic and why you know it's important
that we
know that they say know your enemies
right but these people don't get it
they're like heaven forbid we actually
learn why evil people do things
but i looked at his twitter account and
he had this one as well as part of a
collage or whatever
and he says i don't really it's a guy
about to get his head chopped off i
don't really care about politics
the reason why that's funny is because
it's not the right
that goes around in revolutions with
guillotines the left literally brings
mock guillotines to people's homes jeff
bezos
right yeah so you're lit this is this
actually speaks way more to moderates
and conservatives than anybody else yeah
you can sit there all day and night and
say you don't care and well here comes
the
here comes the chop politics cares about
you well i'll tell you what man
voters say some big city leaders most
reporters
encourage violent protests here's what's
crazy the latest rasmussen reports
national telephone and online survey
finds
that 50 percent of likely u.s voters
believe
political leaders in some major cities
like portland and seattle are
encouraging violent protests
by limiting the police response 31
disagree
and 19 are not sure they say 55
of all voters believe most reporters
identify with the protesters in violent
protest situations
wow i want you to take that one to the
bank when we talk about the silent
majority
55 of all voters believe the reporters
identify
with the violent protesters but that
says all voters
yeah yeah that doesn't just say of
conservatives
yeah i know you know it's everybody
everyone thinks this of conservatives
or sorry the majority does do they give
us the breakdown by conservatives on
this one well
what was the paragraph just above this
republicans what does that say there
this one has to do with uh political
leaders making it worse they say
republicans
72 percent are more likely than
democrats at 33
uh to think these political leaders are
making it worse okay and
unaffiliated is at 48. i don't know what
those numbers represent because but
that's still 33
of the democrats think that the
political leaders are making it worse
yeah leaders plural there yep it's not
just one
i think the journalists love blaming a
certain somebody
so take into consideration the
journalists portion of this 55 percent
of all voters believe most reporters
identify with the protesters
are you going to tell antifa who you're
voting for
when you get a phone call from someone
you believe is part of the violent
protests and they're saying who did you
vote for
yeah uh i'm
vote for biden good click good
that's right you will i know where you
live most reporters
this is the important factor if 55
of voters are lying to reporters because
they believe the reporters
are antifa then our polls are
insanely skewed yeah i already think
awesome insanely you know this means
it means that the polls are beyond
inverted
if okay so consider this 45 percent of
people answering polls
and we're just speculating here this is
we're not i'm not i'm you know
extrapolating some data here we're
taking a little leap
if 55 of voters think protesters are
anti-fun it stands to reason you're not
going to tell an auntie foe who you're
voting for you're not gonna tell the
truth at least right
so we're all so that means those 55
percent are lying
so if that means 45 are being honest
which includes a small portion of trump
supporters
and then the rest are all saying biden
it's probably right now the actual polls
are trump 80
biden 20. yep that sounds about right i
believe that
we'll see man we'll see man i don't i
think uh i think
hubris will be the downfall of of either
side you think
you won you didn't you better show up
and vote that's all that matters i've
i've never been more
more stoked to vote for somebody in my
entire life and that's
and i've heard i've heard similar things
people the life doesn't want to believe
it man
because i've tweeted about this over and
over again so uh i mentioned this before
i would love to actually i'm talking to
my friend about
promoting their twitter account okay but
this is somebody who's not
you know a public figure at all okay i
met somebody at a black lives matter
rally okay yeah your friend six years
ago okay
who's who even up to last year was
posting f trump f trump
black lives matter and then all of a
sudden i see she's posting all these
crazy ass
donald trump memes and i'm like what is
going on
i sent her a dm i'm like you're voting
for trump now and she's like definitely
and i was like but i met you at a black
lives matter rally yeah she's like
right yup but yup it unit has to do with
it has to do with epstein
ah yep yeah cause trump's dropping the
hammer on all them
there's a lot they're scared they're
they're scared you can tell
mike cernovich tweeted something really
really funny okay and
uh he especially deserves a lot of
credit on this one because he's the one
who filed the suits
to get the documents unsealed oh wow
yeah it's really it's really crazy
people don't realize this mike cernovich
has actually broken
tons of huge news stories just killing
it the media doesn't want to acknowledge
this guy
oh yeah they smear him they lie or they
just omit his name entirely wow really
yeah but he's he's
absolutely responsible and then to a
certain degree i'm trying
i don't want to steal credit from
anybody else there's julie k brown of
the miami herald
okay who they were both involved but i
think cernovich was the first could be
wrong but i know that he played a a
large role in this
but uh now that i've been praising his
work on epstein oh yeah he tweeted
he tweeted that right now you've got
this big q on protest
in hollywood okay and all the mainstream
journalists are mocking and belittling
them for like crazy conspiracy stuff
okay i definitely think a lot of these
people believe some crazy conspiracy
stuff
though to be honest i don't follow it
you know seriously
but cernovich said he responded
basically saying
you've got these main i'll paraphrase
the general idea
it's no wonder that these people believe
that or
refuse to believe mainstream news and
end up believing conspiracies
when they've been demanding the press
cover bill clinton on
you know on the island i'm going to be
very careful with language because
youtube will give us the axe
well he was bill clinton for those who
don't named
he was named directly by uh virginia
dufrey
yeah she id'd him saying there's
testimony from 2016
that's got that got released thanks to
cernovich where she straight up like
clinton was there
end of story yep so she saw him with
not just not just younger right things
were happening while
they were there with young women and so
what cernovich points out is you you
have people
who end up believing conspiracies
because we know for a fact when these
transcripts when these documents get
released and there is some good
journalists revealing this stuff
no one else covers it yeah because they
don't want anyone looking at that stuff
that's why
it's political but it's also having to
do with antifa
these people believe that these these
these journalists are antifa and they
are correct these people are aligned
ideologically with these far-left
militant extremists yep
so when you watch a video and you see a
guy
lob an explosive and the department of
justice says
we've got him he's being arrested and
then you turn on the media and they're
like peaceful protesters and you're like
what i watched the video man yep
it drives you inside throws it it's true
lights it tosses it
it explodes here's another paddling
lights on fire
i'm not surprised there are people who
refuse to believe mainstream news and
end up getting their news from fringe
conspiracy groups because
at least the fringe conspiracy groups
are talking about antifa being violent
well i mean bill clinton if you look
into it it's not
there there is some fringe conspiracy
stuff but a lot of it actually
is corroborated like it's legitimate
proven stuff that they're talking about
that the mainstream media
isn't talking about so i mean
yeah there's there's some conspiracy in
it but for the most part i mean a lot of
it's been proven
no it's a lot of it's it's a big mess of
insane conspiracy garbled mumbo jumbo
well yes it's become it's become more
and more because it feels like they're
trying to to
smoke the whole the whole uh q movement
with these crazy sides there's there's
there's there's a lot more problems with
with cue going back to its entire
history of failed predictions and kind
of just garbled nonsense
okay but what happens is no one will
trust the mainstream news
if the mainstream news is trying to
debunk it because we know they're lying
about things we can see with our own
eyes
so what happens is people become very
susceptible to conspiracy theories
if you see a story on the internet and
it says antifa
lobs you know bomb if you watch this
show for instance yeah
and we we we showed the clip from and we
didn't play it but we show that doj
posts this and uh actually can i pull it
up right here here we go
a portland man has been charged with
arson and here's the video published
by the doj and you can see a dude
look there's the flashlight you can
watch it go on twitter you can see this
a verified doj account
yeah if we know this happened if you
watch the show and you know
this happened and then you see from
every mainstream news source
peaceful protest you see a picture of a
burning building
torched and it says peaceful protest you
watch msnbc
and what was that guy's name who said
peaceful protest in front of the burning
building
i don't remember he's standing in front
of a the police precinct which is being
burned to the ground
peaceful and he's like now now now it's
peaceful it's peaceful
and cnn did the same thing oh yeah i
remember that if you watch that
and you're staring in confusion like i
don't get it
these people are literally insane
they're lying
then when they come out with any other
information you're like i don't buy it i
don't believe it like i was saying
before
they could come out right now and say
you know today donald trump waved hello
to some reporters i'd be like no he
didn't
you're lying it's not true it's fake
news i'm gonna need uh
proof i needed the video and i need the
full 20 minute video of the helicopter
landing
trump walking up waving hello walking
back and then flying away
no he gives the thumbs up that's what he
does he goes yeah see
no he flicks him off and says you're
fake news a fake ass
no no he doesn't cause he's i'm kidding
no i know
i i still i like the guy so you know i
saw i saw videos of a lot of these you
know a lot of the conspiracy protesters
and stuff
and what makes me really angry is that
i'm not going to blame the individuals
for believing conspiracy theories and
fake news
but in the absence of real journalism
it's it's it's the space is exploited by
people who just make things up for
profit
i mean you're also going under the
assumption that anyone that follows q
believes every single thing that they're
talking about and that's not true
i mean the core of it is just garbled
mumbo jumbo there's a huge map
about it's it's not i know i've seen
them international
or an inter-dimensional whatever just
right listen
there's there's a general idea around it
with donald trump going up against
elements of what they call the permanent
government yeah people who retain their
positions after elected officials leave
but you know if if if if you're talking
about people who like passively and
loosely
like mention something without paying
attention to it well then i'd recommend
you actually start looking at what some
of these people are saying
because some of what they're saying is a
lot of insane you know yeah there's
crazy people in every group
yeah but this is primarily nonsensical
garbled mumbo jumbo
they're holding up they're holding up
posters with with pizzas and hot dogs on
it
because somebody made something up on
4chan and they all just believed it was
true
and now i'd be willing to bet there's a
huge i mean i know for a fact a lot of
people believe things are true that are
absolutely not true
because somebody literally posted on a
forum something totally fake
and the problem i have with this is it
makes it impossible to actually dig
into what they were tracking a red
herring was thrown out they chased after
it now they're marching around with
poster boards
saying thing talking about you know
weird conspiratorial things that are
just not true
and that was that was the point you've
got powerful elites
we know they're doing creepy things bill
clinton was just implicated
so we get it but when you come out with
poster boards of things that make no
sense
and one of the princes i don't remember
which prince andrew yeah definitely
implicated
so all you have to say is like it's very
clear-cut
bill clinton prince andrew id'd by
witness what do we get instead
people marching around with gibberish
made up words pictures of
spaghetti and and hot dogs and they look
like they're nuts
because someone posted fake news online
and they were like this is what i'm
going to make a poster board about
yeah instead of being like published
documents
through a lawsuit today as reported by
newsweek
implicate bill clinton yeah those are
crazy instead you get conspiracy can't
believe i read that today
yep that's that's that that's where
we're at so the important thing i always
tell the people it's like
man they're they're a real they're well
there used to be real journalists i
don't think they really exist for the
most part
i'm looking at one right now tim yeah
kind of but you know what we
we sort of do is like a weird
fact-checking commentary show almost you
know
yeah i guess that's true that that
accurately talks about what our show is
yeah i guess so a lot of crazy people
saying a lot of crazy things and i have
no problem
saying it's true it's not true we need
facts on this one
i think we showed that that chart the
other day about
the new york times and the hockey stick
of all the intersectionalism and far
left of stuff starting in like
2010 right and then listen if you get
there's there's so many factors that are
conspiring to create
conspiracy movements it is the fault of
the new york times it is the fault of
the daily beast and vox
yeah they post it so much that it's
convinced these people that believe
no i'm not we're not talking about q
anymore we're talking about the the
crazy left
the the people that are that read all
this and succumb to it
pass it around keep seeing it and pass
it around and it gets worse and worse
and worse
that that is now their new reality
that's what they believe it is 100
that is the way people are and everyone
else is like they're looking at them
like they're the ones holding the pizza
signs like you guys are crazy because
that's not the way it is
so when they say what was that initial
thing the seattle
department said they wanted uh gender
affirming
uh praxis praxis or whatever i'm like
what what is this
praxis is a dog whistle to the far left
okay
trauma-informed gender-affirming
anti-racist praxis
whoa so all of these words are dog
whistles for the far left
in fact the word dog whistle is a dog
whistle to the far left
because regular people don't use these
phrases good point you can tell if
someone is trapped in this bubble
of this this conspiracy world they
really are
white supremacist conspiracy theorists
who believe there is a cabal the
patriarchy that controls everything
it's it's insane here's what happens
the new york times starts telling you
know talking about whiteness
directly insulting people those people
then say i'm done and they turn it off
but they still want to get information
from somewhere and so they go online
they look for it
and they end up finding the inversion of
it enter
tim cast irl well we're here for you to
give you the
real news and try to break it down well
we we try to break it down
what i mean is kind of in terms of where
people end up
a lot of people end up going into insane
conspiracy world
or like facebook meme news land well
that's the left
yeah they start getting all their news
from memes yeah and i'm like
some random person will tweet something
like
the government is so dumb like they
should just give everyone a million
dollars and then all of a sudden i see
like 50 000 shares on facebook and
they're like it makes so much sense
remember the one what was the thing
where it was like what did they say what
did they say it was like uh
uh michael bloomberg spent 500 million
dollars on the election
if he he could have there's 300 there's
300 million americans
he could have given every american a
million dollars and still had money left
over and it's like
no that's a dollar yes like 1.25 like
sorry learn math if you can't even do
that why should we trust you with
anything but that's
what they'll do is they'll take a
screenshot of that insane statement and
that went crazy viral yeah people were
sharing that like can you believe this
look at this can you believe it it's
like
no i can't i can do math no that's crazy
yes everybody would have gotten a dollar
30.
yeah if i think i think you need a
trillion a trillion or something yeah
it's not if he had 500 trillion he could
have given a million dollars yeah yeah
350 million or a trillion yeah right
so all of these people they share memes
for news
they get they get their information half
baked from cnn because they overheard it
at an airport
and then other people are sitting there
and they'll actually it's it's really
it's really easy to get pushed down
say a rabbit hole now the life tries
claiming that youtube does it
it doesn't really that's not true
facebook might through shares though
they've been changing their algorithm
it really just happens if someone sends
you a video
and you see a dude lobbing an explosive
at a building you go
whoa that guy just threw an explosive at
that building what happened
and then you're like but the news isn't
talking about it so i've literally
gotten emails from people where they're
saying things like
i turn on the news in uh you know in
europe
and they're showing all these peaceful
marches and protests and then all of a
sudden you're seeing
you know gas masks and like camo gear
guys shooting at people
right and you're like wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
how did how did how did we get here yeah
wait
they're missing a huge chunk of time
there what
they don't show it do people even
question that though i would question it
like
how did like what spawned them from to
do that because
there's got to be a reason and there was
but they don't show that they just they
they try and make it seem like peaceful
demonstrators were attacked viciously by
trump's secret police
i mean even even my friend in portland
who hit me up
saying like how can you how can you be
okay with this like
i live in portland and it's fine like
i'm not seeing anything like i go
outside everything's normal
nothing's happening so how are you gonna
tell me i live in portland
and there's no there's nothing that's
like i'm watching the
the live streams of the people standing
outside the courthouse
trying to burn the courthouse down like
what do you mean how can
i see it how can't you see it go to the
courthouse
and call me when you get there there
there's a pers the person sitting in the
guillotine saying i don't care about
politics still haven't heard back
that was like a week and a half ago well
i'll tell you what
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify
and we will soon have this podcast up
for free on all podcast platforms
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next episode
you